good afternoon of the rules
committee for Monday April
second is hereby convene
called order please revise in
audio and video recording of
today's person has been made
in the small screen televised
AB sector please call the roll
Cooley here Cunningham Alan
broke it Carillo Cervantes
here's Friedman Grayson less
area solace present Waldron
here we have a have a corpsman
we have the consent agenda
Sir motion on the consent
agenda drum roll moves
-- matter the role Cooley
high Cooley aye cunning
broke my Brough aye Cervantes
Cervantes aye Friedman Grayson
Grayson aye Alex solace I
the motion passed and the
schools could you draw